uh obviously 10 days until election day
you're here in nevada you could be you
know in any state
you know why nevada why is it important
to get the vote out here
because we know nevada is a bellwether
state we have seen it made incredible
progress
and we know with the new voting laws
that are on the books we are seeing a
very very strong push to turn out voices
that haven't been heard before
and in 2020 it is critical that we have
every
person who has the right to vote cast a
ballot and here in nevada
doing that will continue to make change
possible not only in the state but
around the country
and you know today you have a tax
schedule you talked with
um you had a voter suppression uh um
conversation you're speaking to black
women in just a little bit
uh speaking of making sure that all the
voices are heard is that kind of
why you're doing those specific events
trying to get
you know all these voices into the into
the mix we know that progress in
2021 is going to rely on making sure
that every voice is included
i started the day talking to labor
leaders they're talking to folks from
around this
around clark county who care about
reproductive choice who care about
health care
who care about living wages i then had a
chance to talk to black women about
their power to help
change the electorate and just now had a
good opportunity to talk about
what nevada has done right about
restoring the rights of citizens
who may have been incarcerated but are
now newly re-enfranchised
no matter who you are joe biden wants
you to know that you are part of his
america part of our america
and so i'm here to ensure that every
voice can cast a ballot
and can be heard in this election and
obviously it's important
every election for you know the people
who have the the chance to vote to
actually vote
this year why is it more maybe important
than ever
we are in the midst of three crises a
health care catastrophe an economic
depression and a racial reckoning
we need a leader who actually believes
in all of america and unfortunately
there's only one person in this race
who sees all of america and is willing
to work for everyone and that is joe
biden
but we know joe biden needs the
electoral votes it will come out of
nevada
he needs the voices that will come out
of nevada but he also needs a strong
congress
and we've got great leaders who are in
congress now from nevada who need to get
reelected
but we need to go all the way down the
ballot don't stop at the top
elect every single leader who's willing
to be a voice of progress in the state
like i said 10 days away from election
day early voting is in full swing here
in the state
with 10 days left until you know people
can cast their last ballot
what's your big message to voters in
these [ __ ] this final stretch here
we have two messages don't panic and
don't delay
don't let any of the chaos or
distractions stop you from casting your
ballot
but also don't delay we know that there
are 10 days left but it is 2020
and we have to think about election day
as last call we don't know what's going
to happen between now and then
but one thing you can control is making
sure your ballot gets passed so
your ballot gets counted and then
anything else you wanted to say to
nevada voters specifically
i encourage nevada voters to go to
nevadavotesearly.com for more
information or nevadavotas.com
to get access to information we need
every vote to be cast so every vote can
be counted
so we can drive ourselves to progress in
nevada we're counting on you
thank you so much i really appreciate it
thank you